okay so bins gonna entertain us do
something funny or cool when nothing oh
honey so this is some ways my favourite
topic of an optimization what could be
better you're finding the best thing
right here look at this title just got
his name and run big word talk man
really big thing but no I could be
emphasizing all the different fields
that are kind of coming together here
and in every different field opposition
is kind of a central thing what we work
with CS theory been without commercial
optimization sort of driving it along
writing and linear algebra even though
it's about matrices you know Gauss was
solving least squares problems he was
doing an optimization problem and of
course statistics is replete with
maximum likelihood estimation etc it
wouldn't be statistics without
optimization and so this field is still
you know older than many of the other
fields at the same time every sort of
ten years or some there's some brand new
idea and it leaps forward somehow and so
the last ten years with all the kind of
Russian schools all their ideas flooding
the West by the break up the Soviet
Union it's been really refreshing to see
and so been as an expert on that stuff
and you'll probably convey something
excitement thanks Mike uh yeah I think
much of today's talk is actually
borrowed from my lecture notes prepared
by Steven Wright who unfortunately
couldn't join us today because it's the
first day his class
so just suboptimal scheduling but I'm
going to do my best to do the Steve
Wright impression without the Australian
accent and yes how we talk about
optimization which as Mike was saying is
anytime we need to minimize or maximize
some cost and we're subject to some
constraints we have an optimization
problem and I think I think it's quite
clear that's part too much to cover in
three hours and then moreover as Mike's
was pointing out there are lots of
different branches and breeds of
optimization so we can't really do
everything so we want focus is like what
what would actually what are the aspects
of optimization that are kind of most
predominant and salient in whatever this
big
the area is right now so I would say
that not all the time but a large
proportion of the time the problems we
end up solving and looking slightly more
constrained I mean this is justice
actually this is just as general as the
one in the previous slide turns out but
that's fair there's at least this
focuses our attention we're looking at
problems where we're going to minimize
an expectation subject to constraints
that are actually somehow simple the
expectation here we actually will
typically be fairly well behaved this is
going to be some nice distribution which
we're receiving samples from or which we
can we can integrate and when I say the
we're looking at the convex hold a we're
looking at the set a is going to be
simple somehow it's going to have low
description length is going to be
something that we can easily optimize
over and this really does now narrowly
restrict things and at least allows us
to talk about how the complexity of
these optimization problems so we're
also today discuss kind of a closely
related problem where we also have a a
function P which is going to encourage X
to be somehow simple or low complexity
so the idea is trying to find low
complexity models that somehow minimize
expectations more often than not to
minimize agreement with it or maximize
agreement with data is kind of the
problem that we always wanted to solve
if there's not convex only F is going to
be convex not yet not yet we're going to
talk about that but yeah let's not get
ahead of ourselves yet but yes so let me
talk about then give a couple examples
there like canonical and F is always
going to be convex in my examples here
but we'll we'll talk about non convexity
as as things go on so the support vector
machine probably is the also known as
logistic regression or linear regression
by by small permutations one of the most
popular pervasive and important
optimization problems the idea here is
we are given some data they lie in some
space usually Rd so we have d
dimensional vectors everybody has a plus
label or a minus label associated with
them and the goal is to find a
hyperplane that separates these data
points so that your most of the time
labeling examples that come from the
positive reason
with positive numbers and the ones that
come from the negative region with
negative negative numbers and so this
has been very popular in medical
diagnosis in credit card fraud I've
actually worked with some physicists who
who have used this to classify whether
or not cosmic rays are moving up through
their detector or down through their
detector and so you have a variety of
different ways of just kind of coming up
with yes or no answers and the
optimization problem here is actually
pretty easy estate it's you maximize
something which is called the hinge loss
where Y here is the label Z is the
example and X is the hyperplane we're
looking for and you're just trying to
maximize the agreement here if the label
is positive and this dot product is
positive then we don't pay a cost as
long as this is sufficiently large this
is very negative that goes to 0 and if
you get a sign mislabelling it rolls off
linearly and as you see here we have an
average over all the examples and then
we add on a panel that penalty here to
select low complexity model in this case
I'm just taking a really simple one
we're just penalizing the Euclidean norm
you can penalize on the l1 norm if you
would like Asus farce answer or a
variety of other norms the l1 norm comes
up in what's called the lasso which
people have used in compressed sensing
where they would like to reduce the
number of measurements required to
acquire signals or in other kinds of
sparse modeling and sparse statistics
where you're really looking for a set of
covariance that best explained some kind
of phenomena and in this case we've saw
something like this where we have a sum
of squares so at least squares cost AI
here now would be either the data or the
acquisition pattern
bi would be the output and you would
have a penalty on the l1 norm being less
than R so this would now try to
encourage that either a sparse signal or
a sparse signature from your data just
one more example which we've discussed
today is the matrix completion problem
where we have some data array we see a
sparse collection of entries in the data
array we assume that that data array
somehow is low rank because we kind of
assume that maybe a principal components
model would be good enough to explain a
lot of the variants in the data in this
case right that this model obviously has
far fewer parameters then they want on
the other side and so what we could just
do is penalize
some of the squares on the observations
to the model we're looking for and now
here we have the penalty term and we're
going to have a a penalty that's going
to encourage X to be as low ranked as
possible okay so that's that's one other
possible answer so oh I had one more so
here's something actually just more
combinatorial but at what but very
commonly known and I learned this
actually from Chris ptosis book that
this is actually a linear program so
that so if I would like to find a
minimum cut in the graph between two
points then we know that that actually
can be formulated as a linear program
this has been used a lot actually in
data analysis more recently as ways of
doing image segmentation as ways of
doing image fusion fusing ways of doing
topic modeling and editing resolution
and this actually you could write it
down as an LP or if we kind of squint a
little bit what this is is minimizing
the sum over all edges that are present
in my graph you put each of the vertices
is assigned a vector and 0 1 and then on
some set you'll have ones that will be
fixed some sets you'll have zeros that
will be fixed and this will actually
solve that LP you know actually turns
out that this problem you will either
get a 1 or a 0 and that's the only
solution on all the vertices but it does
have that form now we can actually think
about this graph being random and now
think about that being an expectation as
well ok so that's kind of like system
canonical examples is kind of going
through kind of the generality of what
we've been of how we can model certain
data analysis problems ok so just to
kind of just refocus why do we care
about optimization is everywhere there
were some examples we just gave almost
anything can actually always be reverse
engineered into an optimization problem
so you can always it gets almost to the
point where everything becomes
optimization one of the really nice
features is its modular so that if you
have some two different kinds of
modeling of simplicity
you can join both of those constraints
and try to solve that optimization and
provided you have convexity or something
similar you can actually just solve the
resulting composite optimization problem
as well and it's also what's interesting
for I think people who do things like
sequel and databases is optimization is
inherently declarative it seems to kind
of youyou kind of state what you like
you know I'd like it to be sparse and
low rank
I'd like to minimize something I would
like to minimize this function subject
to these constraints and almost by just
stating that not only have you posed the
problem well but we'll see if we
actually have algorithms that will just
naturally solve it as well so what kind
of allows us to take algorithm design a
little bit out of the outside the loop
now you could specialize and focus and
really kind of hone in and get a very
specialized algorithm but what's nice
about this is that for people who don't
want to be optimization specialists you
can really make packages now and there
are a lot of them CVX TF o CS CVX off I
could there a bus where you can you
really just state the problem and if you
state the problem in a reasonably
disciplined way you can hope you can be
assured that the solution that comes out
will be the one that you want it so you
don't have to think necessarily about
algorithms ok so let me focus on what am
I going to talk about what aspect am i
going to talk about we hope we honed in
on some data analysis problems and I
want to look at the space of problems
that can be solved by iterations that
kind of look like this we take an
iterate XK which is what the solution
we're looking for we add to it a vector
V which is hopefully some direction
that's going to improve our cost and
that's our that's our that's our
algorithm this is typically gradient
descent and that's what we're going to
spend all today discussing is kind of
how far can we push gradient descent and
great descent like algorithms to solving
those kinds of of problems that arise in
data analysis and what we'll see is that
basically what we'll there are a variety
of kind of special cases there's the
conjugate gradients and accelerant
gradient methods there are stochastic
gradient which are really kind of
dealing with the fact that our data is
random and it's coming from some random
process there are projected gradients
which allow us to incorporate
constraints and essentially what we'll
see we'll go through each of these three
topics and then basically you can mix
and matches at will any of these
ingredients you can accelerate the
proximal method with stochastic losses
you can do a variety of different kinds
of it's very modular even in this kind
of
so that's today's lecture tomorrow we're
going to talk about duality and because
the other thing that optimization is
very good for is proving things
especially convex optimization convex
optimization all gives you tools to do
average case analysis of a lot of david'
data analysis problems because this is
prevalent machine learning this is kind
of the whole idea behind generalization
bounce tomorrow I'm going to focus on
one example from compressed sensing kind
of going through the machinery that
we've seen a random matrix theory and
how that ties in with complex
optimization to prove things about the
number of measurements you need to
recover sparse signals so we'll actually
walk through that tomorrow will be a
whiteboard talk which and we'll go
through kind of nitty-gritty details and
but what we can actually complete from
from zero to a proof kind of some of the
basic compressed sensing results just
using some notions from duality for the
I mean this is kind of been known in
combinatorial optimization for a long
time but why this is powerful I mean
this basically if you have a min/max
characterization of your problem that
essentially immediately lands you in NP
intersect Co MP if I can if I can
basically test whether the value of a
primal example I could test the value of
dual example now I have a short proof
and a short certificate and so it's not
entirely true but MP intersect Co MP
usually aren't too bad but usually
that's a good place to be and that
typically can lend you land you to P
which is what I think one of the really
interesting things about duality and
we'll see you tomorrow is that's kind of
also this is the basis of many proof
techniques in machine learning and
signal processing and obviously in
Contra optimization okay but we'll get
to that tomorrow so for today let's go
back to the gradient descent and let me
just list I mean I tried to put one
slide of what we're skipping I could I
could probably go on for an hour and a
half about what I can't talk about isn't
half and a half so I'm going to skip
over things like second order
information which are incredibly
important as I think are kind of the
frontier where we should be going kind
of incorporating extra information that
allows algorithms to converge faster I'm
going to skip over the interior point
method the ellipsoid method is all these
kind of second-order methods that people
probably know and love I'm gonna skip
over after set methods
manifold identification and really kind
of the really cutting-edge techniques
and nonlinear programming
I got skip over branch-and-bound which
is also and all these other branching
cuts and these other things that are
quite useful for solving difficult
problems and really I'm kind of going to
leave out all the combinatoric which is
too bad but hopefully we can start
integrating those things back in
throughout the semester I'm going to
skip derivative free optimization I like
derivatives I'm actually probably gonna
skip mostly I'll talk a little bit about
non smooth optimization but for the most
part we're going to assume that our
functions are smooth today I'm going to
skip heuristics okay I've got the most
important thing I'm skipping kind of the
most important thing about optimization
is I'm skipping modeling I think that's
actually really underappreciated part of
optimization it's not just enough to be
able to solve the problems when they're
given to you it's about being able to
pose them it's kind of like half of the
battle just being able put essentially
just like at least squares for convex
optimization if we can pose a convex
optimization problem usually the
algorithm we can get a polynomial time
algorithm for sure
get an efficient algorithm a lot of the
times too so that's kind of a longer
conversation okay let's go back start
with the simple thing minimizing
function f subject to X in RN F is now
done completely unconstrained lesson
students smooth so what do we do we
search for a point with the gradient
Vantage's and we basically turn this
geometry problem into an algebra problem
and say 5 million x where that gradient
goes away and this is necessary for for
X to be optimal and sufficient for
convex smooth F and hopefully everybody
seen something to that effect before
okay good so basically we want to say
how do we find a point where the
gradient vanishes so the great descent
idea is basically trying to do a fixed
point iteration so come on so we start
with a point we start with our curve we
have our point we find a direction that
goes downhill to reduce the function and
we walk along it so let's let us see how
actually how we analyze it kind of just
under that notion that we're looking for
a fixed point so here V is just going to
be the negative of the gradient and so
we're going to say when it
assume that this map which takes X and
matches the X minus alpha grad F and
that's just going to our gradient
mapping let's assume it's contraction so
if I take two points I apply that
gradient map I look at their difference
that's always less than beta times their
norm where beta is less than 1 okay so
we assume that the gradient map itself
is contractive okay so what does that
mean that means that gradient descent is
going to converge
it's actually really trivial to see that
it is law as you have a contraction you
get convergence and the reason why I'm
going to kind of belabor this is what
we'll see is that every proof of
convergence sign this is a little over
generalizing but today every proof of
convergence is just going to define the
invariant to be the distance to the
optimal solution and then do some
manipulation and you'll show that that
decreases and that guarantees that you
converge so in this case we just plug in
the definition of our iteration we use
the fact that X star is a fixed point
the great advantage is that's the fixed
point of that map that rewrites it this
way and then we have a contraction and
then we repeat a bunch of times and we
get down to something like this where we
say that after K steps or K plus 1 steps
where beta to the k plus 1 times our
original distance so that means we have
an exponential convergence which
optimization people call linear
convergence whatever there's a reason
you call it linear it's really this step
it's just saying that the difference
between the current area in the next
area is a linear function but it ends up
being an exponential rate of convergence
so basically what we just said is that
if this gradient map is contractive then
we converge exponentially quickly it
turns out that there's something else
that's underlying all this convex
optimization essentially if your
function if your gradient descent is
converging exponentially that means
you're minimizing a convex function just
it so this we could walk through this
proof again we're going to look at this
side which remember is just the map that
max X to x minus grad X and we'll just
reformulate it so we'll say X and we'll
just take a step plus Delta X just a
small infinitesimal step and divide by
that step size okay and so that's just
the definition of contract
and so if I take the limit as T goes to
zero what you see is you'll get this
expression you'll get the Delta X minus
alpha times the Hessian of F times Delta
X but what in this limit each of these
guys is less than beta X so the
resulting limit is also less than beta X
and what that means is that the norm of
this matrix this is now a linear matrix
has to be less than beta okay so
basically why by assuming this map is
contractive that actually means that
this function which is the identity
matrix minus alpha times the Hessian is
has nor less than 1 and writing that out
a nice positive definite notation that
means that basically the Hessian is
sandwiched between a multiple D identity
and the other multiples identity this
lower side means that the function is
positive definite and hence that means
that F is convex so essentially by
assuming that we have contractility that
means we're actually it's the same as
assuming convexity actually with this
called strong convexity and the top one
basically just assumes that our
gradients obey the ellipsis condition so
convexity as we're having you just kind
of knew in advance it's unavoidable in
some sense if we're doing nonlinear
optimization if you actually go to old
nonlinear optimization books they prove
things in generality for general smooth
functions but then you go and look at
the proof and they say assuming that you
are in a basin around a local solution
where you have a convex ball so
everything in the proof is basically
assuming convexity you're assuming that
you're somehow in a convex well and
that's why I mean it's basically once
you assume that you're going to get an
exponential convergence you are locally
in a convex region so what does compacts
mean again well it's just that the lines
above the function stay above the
function that's a useful notion but
actually what in optimization really
what the better definition or the more
useful definition for convexity is this
one so for smooth functions basically
you want to say that they this red line
just defined over here is always under
the function okay so this is a linear
approximation we basically take the
gradient direction at X look at the
under approximation and if I add on if I
actually say something stronger which is
that the function is now f of Z is now
bigger than this linear approximation
plus an extra term that's called strong
convexity the other thing that I say
automatically happen when you assumed
contractivity was that the gradient was
Lipschitz that actually just but this
actually just follows from Taylor's
theorem that means that you actually
have an upper bounds you have an upper
and lower bound by these quadratics
essentially the convergence theory is
just kind of pushing these two upper and
lower bounds together well you see if
you solve this one just minimize it
minimize this approximation this upper
approximation what you'll see is you'll
sit you'll that will just be see we're
going to minimize it with respect to Z
that will basically just take us from X
and add on the gradient so minimizing
this function is actually taking a
gradient step and so that's where you
see you would walk down the hill to this
point and then successively walk down
the hill until you hit the bottom ok so
if I define this number Kappa which is
the ratio of the strong convexity
parameter to the Lich's parameter that's
always bigger than 1 it's called the
condition number less than 1 got
backwards always less than 1 and I got
it I got it upside down so I apologize
here will divert that since that's going
to come up over and over again without
being defined Kappa is capital L divided
by little L so in figure than 1 all
right typo number one right that's
called the condition number of the
Hessian is basically telling us how
oblong is the is the decision surface
and the kind of the the key point is
that I can tune a constant step size
alpha take this 2 over L what this is
just algebra you basically just kind of
optimize your constants a bit you get
this rate of convergence so the rate of
convergence is two divided by the
condition number plus 1 to decay
or if you'd like you can do that in
terms of the function value and you get
the same rate of convergence depending
on what you're more interested in so
it's two over the condition number plus
one one minus that number so what this
tells you is this this function if the
condition number is huge this is very
close to one so even though you have an
exponential rate of convergence it's a
very slow exponential so now I did
everything here in this kind of very
kind of squishy picture where we just
had this constant step size I over tuned
it I got this L plus L usually we don't
know these parameters but there are
actually ways that are very good at
adapting to these parameters these are
things called line search where what
you'll do is you'll take a step and then
you'll try to find a good step that's
really giving you a good decrease in
your function and what's nice is that
these local line searches both in terms
of backtracking line search exact line
search there's thousands of these if you
want to go look at some old hardcore
non-linear programming books from the
70s there are lots of different versions
of what to do here and they all can
basically the number of gradient steps
in terms of the number of gradient steps
you get this rate of convergence however
you do need to do this live search which
will cost you some function evaluations
so there's a little bit of a trade-off
between the number how good of a line
search you do and what your rate of
convergence is but the point is that
what the other esting thing is that even
if you do these very sophisticated line
searches you don't beat what you get
with a constant step size so essentially
if you if somehow somehow someone handed
down that information about these the
strong convexity parameter and lift just
parameter you should just use those and
that should be fine so what happens so
here's my function this has I can tell
you it's just this is just a
two-dimensional quadratic with condition
number 100 and let's say we start at
that red dot and we run the gradient
method this is what it would do so this
is the example where we have a linear
rate of convergence but this is about 40
steps and it's still a pretty slow
linear rate
so any questions up to this stage this
is kind of like our canal hopefully this
is maybe you guys have even seen this as
undergrads yeah Dave towers with it
better to come virgin to that optimal it
will get there eventually you're just
going to be waiting a while
I still don't capture the intuition the
geometric theory but it's slow geometric
rate right because it's just one minus
the number that's really close to one I
mean for all intents and purposes I
could make that bad as I'd like you know
just make that one minus one over you
know so just gets 1 over 100 you know
you can make this really really bad
numbers all right but the question is
how large so in this case it says that
even in practice large could be very
large so a question is can we do better
than the gradient method a trap you the
gradient be pointing more towards the
center there well so what the gradient
that so these are the contour lines so
these are and they're decreasing so it's
high low lower and the gradient points
perpendicular to the contour lines and
that's the problem here so we're in this
well it's like basically like doing a
halfpipe that's what we're doing back
back and forth very slowly not shot
whitestyle that was taking us a while to
get down to the bottom so the question
is like how do we bet can we do better
than the gradient method can we do
better the great method if all we're
willing to do is compute gradients so
one thing that people that you may know
of is something called Newton's method
I'm not going to talk about that today
that's actually not really well paired
to a computation on large data this but
this algorithm tends to scale linearly
with the dimension the gradient method
Newton's method tends to scale cubic ly
with the dimension and that's typically
prohibitive for high dimensional
problems as density cut it out favor
we'll do a comparison of all these later
but so I prefer not to do Newton's
method I would just like to do a better
gradient method so this leads us to the
notion of acceleration also what this is
going to be called which I think the
best name for an algorithm ever this
will lead us to the optimal method
and always good when you have an optimal
method but you know off multi with
respect to what we'll see so the optimal
optimization method okay so one way to
think about this nap right it's like a
five difference approximation to this
OTE okay so we're basically following a
differential equation which is this
potential well now how do I make up if I
have word my is Josh you're still Nazis
not here so I could single out the
physicist so if I have a potential well
and I would like to make it not
oscillate what do I do I add friction
this is kind of something we do in
mechanics so so basically what I would
do is I would go from a second-order
different first order differential
equation to a second-order one adding a
term proportional to the derivative and
that will prevent oscillation so just
adding friction should slow down the
oscillations in this function
essentially if I route the final dist
first approximation I get something
without two time lags or another way
actually the way I like to write it is
that's just two equations we have we're
taking a step along P P used to be the
negative gradient but now it's the
negative gradient plus a memory term so
we're damping the gradient we're saying
we're going to go kind of in the
direction we were in before this is a
two-step method it's a multi-step method
and this will tend to be faster called
the heavy ball method was invented by
Pollock in the Soviet Union in the 60s
in the case that is quadratic Michael's
not here but that's all right this is
this is known as chebyshev's iterative
method so Michael talks about this in a
lot in his last talk is something that
he was actually funding would be a
better algorithm than conjugate gradient
in a lot of implementations in terms of
communication and the reason you'll see
in a second I will bring back conjugate
gradient you can write it almost in the
same way except we're just going to
change alpha and beta
you have to dynamically adapt alpha and
beta in the case of the conjugate
gradient method here we just have
constant alpha constant beta yeah
the issue was you have to have pretty
strong guarantees on your conditioning
but intuitively it seems to you that
you're precisely using in a case where
conditioning is nasty yeah in order
precisely to improve faster imitations
of kind of a naive gradient that's right
in your face of bad conditioning can you
sort of sort out but that kind of
intuitive let me smash that I have yeah
absolutely so let me let me show why
kind of irons out conditioning and then
second I'm going to get exactly to the
thing that the parameters you need and
then third I'll get to this weird
Nesterov algorithm that gets around
actually having to know anything so
maybe even better than the conjugate
gradient so let's good we'll do that in
that order so the first is just here is
my ellipsoid again my really zoomed in
on red so that was our gradient step
perpendicular to the contour there is my
gradient step back but if I take a
mixture of these two directions I would
actually go there you go I want to go to
Peru
should be awesome so this basically so I
was going this way but I'm going to cut
push myself in this direction so I go
this way
that's my and if I actually I run that
for the same number of steps I converge
so I am fine tuning this with I have the
exact parameters here these are the best
parameters for gradient descent this is
the best parameters for this heavy ball
method really does make a big difference
so how do we analyze it again the who
has a physics background here oh yeah we
can go back right energy-wise you're
going to be going uphill what so better
off you're adding more force actually so
that's what's interesting is that you're
using friction but that allows you to
actually drive with more force and
that's why you get to the if you're
going to use the same idea the step
sizes are bigger but now you have a
friction term that kind of damped you so
it actually allows you to come like
swing your pendulum harder because
you're actually allows you to converge
faster
welljust is so the grading method is
driven to your taking steps right you
have this fixed step size and that's
kind of forcing that's how much of the
potential you're using so it has that
forcing term this lets you take even
bigger steps so I was just a sink but
tonight I mean its momentum rather than
fiction right you are going more I mean
you are adding to your direction the
last direction not subtracting adding
the last direction yes right so this a
funny word yeah I see sometimes I hear a
momentum it that's one of those that's
right it is the momentum method that's
right and this is a momentum because
it's using that last last term but
they're kind of the same thing cuz if
you're proportional to the derivative
right I mean that's kind of damping you
some size if you make the negative it
diverges off to think about that let me
not get too distracted but that's a good
question that's a good question you have
to leave asleep all the physics huh just
some equations they do go down they do
go downhill well let's let slavishly
follow the physics though now we're
going to go back let's go back to our
second gyro de classe as to see how to
actually analyze this so basically with
the way that you the way that ploy a
eise's it which i think it's just
beautiful and the reason why i'm going
through the heavy ball method is for
anyone who's actually tried to look at
the analysis of Nesterov method or even
the back into bull version of Nessarose
method is incredibly counterintuitive
and the way that the way that our
cutting nemirovsky was one of these
common russian school of optimizers
characterizes these as there is no what
there is no intuition there is purely
computation so you just cut or sorry
calculation purely calculation you get
everything so it lines up and you get a
solution however pulley axe method
poetic with nester ops advisor it's very
intuitive it's just you know you need
these parameters you kind of have to
know a lot more than Nesterov does so
basically the idea is instead of having
a Lyapunov function with just the
current iterate you have now additions
to the current iterate and the distance
to the previous it to the optimal
solution you take your your if we
linearize this so basically i'm assuming
this is quadratic our step is basically
a matrix times our previous w plus low
order term and
me being a physicist little this is
little Oh in the physic sense in terms
of we ignore it
not little own the computational
complexity sets in terms of maybe that's
a but I think they're similar its small
so when we linearize it basically have
this matrix which this was the the
hessian that had we know the condition
number of and we're adding on this kind
of shift matrix so if i go back again
here we have your Hessians plus one plus
beta minus beta is zero the lambda here
i just analyzed it though the eigen the
dot the eigenvalues of this hashim and
the point is by by choosing alpha and
beta now if you set beta to 0 you get
the gradient method back all right
there's a set banner - yeah you set beta
to zero you get the great it method back
you just take a step i - the hessian now
and that's the thing we were analyzing
but if I actually have a nonzero beta
what I will get is something where I can
analyze what the eigenvalues do and now
you just you know you write out your
yeah you run out of quadratic equation
you try to find the optimal values you
get something messy so this is the key
point
well fine this is the optimal values of
alpha and beta and and I don't know how
you know these things you have to know
the condition number if the lift is
constant if you have to know that's it
okay but still we don't necessarily know
those things but if you were to know
those parameters the rate of convergence
you get is 1 minus root K root condition
number plus 1 over 2 that's much better
that's much better so you know we're
just comparing these two rates so in one
case we had kappa for the gradient
method the other case we have root Kappa
for the heavy ball method all right so
we have these two methods that are
related to each other now one way to
rewrite it is let's say I wanted to get
to some I would like to get my current
area to be epsilon times the original
distance then the number of iterations
for gradient descent is capital over 2
log 1 over Epsilon but for the heavy
ball method is root cap over 2 log 1
over epsilon that's a huge difference I
mean it's like a factor if Kappa is a
hundred like it was in my example that's
10 times yours
which is caught what we were seeing okay
all right so that's the notion we asked
we had this momentum term the momentum
term drives this is zero faster and it
is a big difference and qualitatively
this is what you will see the picture
that you've shown yeah I mean this is
part of the reason I mean doesn't this
usually overshoot come back or refuse to
come back yeah but it's because you're
taking a way to go come on
this clicker is being your your step is
actually much bigger you're taking a
bigger step but then it comes back
because again you're continuing along
the direction that you were previously
moving why don't you go to silver their
order meaning they're in order okay
excellent question
wait two slides as a good as an
excellent question this will get to
optimality yes exactly
there's an excellent question let me
first just say relate to another
algorithm to think more people are
familiar with which is conjugate
gradients all kind of your gradients is
the exact same thing except I have time
varying alpha K and beta K so alpha K
what you do is you pick a line search to
make the function minimize as much as
possible in the case of quadratic you
would actually do this exactly and beta
K in the case of quadratic you do to
make sure that all of your momentum
terms are conjugate in the a basis
meaning they're they're mutually
orthogonal with respect to the quadratic
form a it doesn't really make sense for
nonlinear you're just like that and
that's why these algorithms are but
nonlinear conjugate gradient they're
like five different algorithms for beta
and they're all fragile in their own way
so this was complices that you have this
was developed not only your conjugate
gradient was developed in the in the
West during the Cold War
it's very greedy so you've met you try
to minimize the line search as much as
you possibly can and you choose these
betas to really really force these
directions to be orthogonal even though
they probably don't want to be
the very greedy method as opposed to the
the rep method is developed in the
Soviet Union which I'll get to in a
second which are more patience because
you're waiting in line to get a potato
so I so we have trade-offs here we have
trade-offs here ah so so was it what's
interesting is this this one does not
receive the better rate than heavy ball
and in fact that people have looked if
you look in Goldman van loan at the
optimal rate of convergence for the
conjugate gradient method it was the one
that was on the previous slide this is
one minus one over square root of K it
square root of Kappa that's the best you
can do even for conjugate radius if
you're treating conjugate grading
iterative method like a high dimensional
case but this does get around having to
another parameters and as I said the
convergence proofs are very sketchy your
good convergent proofs for the quadratic
case but for the nonlinear case it's not
not so cut and dry so the question is
how do you get better how you actually
get around having to know know the
parameters alpha beta that you should be
searching for how do you actually kind
of like get something where you don't
need to know the parameters and you
actually have very rigorous convergence
proofs and that's where Nesterov za flow
method comes in and extras optimal
method is exactly the same it's the same
algorithm plus one modulo thing you take
the gradient at somewhere else lesson
bothers me this is called an extra
gradient it basically you take a step
kind of where you think you're going in
the future it's called the N that's also
kind of a classic thing from the 60s and
optimization so it's including it's like
really combining lots of interesting
different ideas you have the
acceleration and this extra gradient the
extra grading it seems necessary to make
the proofs work but as I said I've yet
to have someone explain to me why these
proofs you mean again there is no
intuition there is purely calculation so
for these proofs you get two or three
page proofs there's one in Nessarose
book back and it will have their own if
you look there the proofs that they use
assume that you have you kind of have an
estimate of what the strong convexity
parameter is you can actually get rid of
this with a very weak line search that
basically just does a little bit of back
off so you actually don't need to know
this number both the proofs use it and
then the beta term is just this crazy
algebraic equation
which knows the condition number again
Nesterov has recently what's interesting
is he came up with this method three the
Western people when he republished it in
two thousand four in two thousand and so
on we're kind of set that you have to
know this kappa and subsequently in like
2007 he was able to come up with a way
of actually estimating that number two
at least getting a number such that you
would get the rate that we were talking
about before this one over that start to
over root Kappa minus one subsequently
back into bool have a somewhat simpler
analysis and somewhat simpler scheme
this is actually the one that people use
in practice this is not guaranteed
actually to this often in practice will
get this kind of optimal convergence
rate but actually ten this can be
dreadfully slow so it's actually not a
very robust choice and actually I've
seen in practice that these two are
pretty much the same and I like this one
Paul sang has a nice analysis that just
says this is all you need for that beta
term so you want something that tends to
one alright so that's the that's that's
what next row is also a method is it's
really just using this notion of
momentum to speed up the gradient method
and now we return to the the really
important question why is it optimal
what's awesome so here is the function
that is often before very say it's a
quadratic and actually that's not
surprising because plotting a gradient
such a good algorithm there's not much
there must be a reason I think I think
if you go and look at luan burgers proof
of the conjugate gradient rate he's
using one of these quadratics so this is
basically you have a function in RN
you're just looking at pairwise
differences and squaring them nice like
Markov chain and then we're adding a
penalty to make it strongly convex you
can also turn that off and Nesterov also
uses that to show that his algorithm is
even optimal when the function is convex
but not strongly convex but this
function will be strongly convex and
actually you can show that the smallest
eigen value will be mu and the largest
one will be at most four plus mu
basically in the limit as n goes to
infinity saturates the muon for plus mu
okay
so the condition number is about this
number one plus four of MU you can set
that to be whatever you want and so
here's here's how you prove that this is
optimal but this is only optimal if you
assume that what you're allowed to do is
compute function evaluations and compute
gradients okay those are our tool tools
that we're allowed to do you can
evaluate the function you can compute a
gradient and then you can do whatever
you want on the side but that's like the
Oracle model that's all that the
function is going to tell you okay so
after K steps if I'm applying the
gradient what you'll see you're only
going to get one component at a time
because the grading is basically going
to shuffle you you start at the first
component you look at the gradient
you're only going to get information
about the first term here and then I do
two steps and long-ago net formation
about the first two terms and so after K
steps the my solution is equal to zero
in all the components this is actually a
terrible notation I just mean all the
components XJ to the end are are equal
to zero so the first K components can
have something maybe we're actually
we're going to set them optimally and
then on this orthogonal complement it
just it has to be zero because the
gradient hasn't told us anything to put
fit on fill in there we have no better
idea of what to put in there and so
within the norm of the optimal solution
on the NC components is exactly equal to
the convergence rate of the gradient of
this of Nesterov method and that's
that's the proof so basically that
conjugate gradient rate is just given by
this this is sometimes called a
resisting Oracle but it's basically
something which is just you're not
getting information out of the function
at a fast enough rate and that's why
they don't do you could do third order
and it might be better in practice again
this is the problem with optimality is
right soft Malheur like optimal for a
Markov chain starting at that point so
in practice you can do considerably
better there's really good applause you
know classes it's a little passing of a
path exactly that's what exactly what it
is questions yeah
it's ultimate only put I mentioned three
with us because hear us use it ah yeah
yeah yeah Sebastian making good point
this is true for the conjugate gradient
method two basically we're kind of
assuming here that the dimension is so
big that we can ignore those factors so
we're almost taking this as being an
infinite dimensional problem to get this
rate so that kind of an asymptotic an
always chase it to make it bigger if you
have in fixed dimension you could
possibly do better but it's kind of
weird to work on algorithms that are
only in I don't know you could do it
some of the do is pizza and you could
beat that but no you just use you use
extra for me I mean you use the fact
that basically you're going to fill in I
mean eventually you'll fill in after key
steps you'll have full information so
you could do better so you can beat that
rate after D we can do better but it's
the idea that if I can keep making the
dimension bigger I can keep coming up
with functions somehow having D be a
resource right up to building high order
information from memory yeah exactly
another question the the argument
coordinate structure is gone so
everybody gets rotated I mean I guess I
prefer a rotated II one it would still
be bad you're saying let's say how about
this you're saying what happens if I
started a random e a random vector yeah
yeah then you get a different rate
because now you're taking Android I
haven't done that calculation but I
don't think would be hard to do because
what you're going to do is you're going
to take energy basically the gradient
method is like taking energy from each
of the modes so it's like analyzing the
convergence of every mode now instead of
just this kind of sequence this worst
mode so you have to do you look at the
eigen structure and then calculate those
rates and you can see
the Keynesians three holes from a
different point no you get it you get
something else here I just don't know
what you would get no this is really
like this very it's a very kind of
fragile optimality result but it's
certainly something is that an example
where you can't do better so but but
agree is it there's actually there's
something very weird and pessimistic
about these rates and actually I feel
like I feel like so this is a slide
where I'm going to go yellow my machine
learning friends I feel like in some
sense we're kind of wasting our time
kind of quibbling about the difference
in rates so if you take away the strong
convexity take away strong convexity
then what do we get now we're going to
get something very a very dramatically
different convergence rate the gradient
descent you get a very similar analysis
and the optimal method you get a very
similar analysis but instead getting a
linear rate of convergence
now we're getting something that's
converging inversely proportional to the
number of iterations or number
iterations squared I think the key thing
that you want to take aways this one is
somehow quadratic be better than this
one that's the thing to take away that
the Comeau mentum is speeding enough but
not necessarily that we can really trust
that these race mean anything because
they are always tuned to particular
Oracle's so I and and actually something
that we're going to see in a second is
actually the optimal method is not a
robust method so if we were to say
instead of having a great and Oracle
have a noisy gradient Oracle all this
would get washed out so everything has
to be taken with a grain of salt we have
but we can analyze some things we kind
of know what the worst-case behavior is
and we kind of know what an average kiss
behavior is and we try to kind of stitch
these together so any questions at that
point about momentum or acceleration or
gradients is not robust annoys here's
the problem though it's not robust
annoys but if in machine learning
problems if you can add a momentum term
just a constant momentum it often makes
a difference so again this is this very
odd thing where like we can have we can
either want I don't know this is
actually something that's always kind of
tricky in algorithms we can have things
that have guarantees or we can have
things that maybe are
ingredients in our toolkit that we can
try to bring out I think the momentum is
something is just an idea that you want
to have on your tool belt as something
you could bring out that possibly could
make your behavior better when you're
conditioning is weird but again we can
prove things where we want to know when
it goes re and we'll go Oreo as soon as
you have noise which is what I'm going
next so we'll see that in a sec other
questions my life about this we're
basically doing we're gonna do a
semester in an hour and a half is gonna
be good haha we have our key ingredient
on Quebec City I love not convection
because it's like non convexity it just
means not convex so they're really house
so it's a very very so in some sense we
got think what is non convexity actually
going to buy us um if the function is
smooth and non convex we can still
actually efficiently find a point where
the the gradient nearly vanishes just
run great is the great invent that you
will find a point and the analysis is
very simple and the time is now instead
of being one of our epsilon is one over
epsilon squared so let's slower has a
characteristic and being slower but
there's a something that I can never get
over about non convex things you really
want to I think you want to look at the
particularity of your non convexity I
think non convexity just means not
convex so if you have a non convex
problem you might want to bring
something else to the table to do the
analysis because for example not the
basically this lets you model anything
so so here's here's my favorite non
convex function okay it's just a song
it's a quadratic form of arbitrary
definiteness to some coefficients X I
squared X J squared fourth order
polynomial and dimension D and zero no
matter what you do is always the
gradient vanishes there okay so when the
gradient vanishes you have a point
that's either a local maximum a local
minimum or something else right
something else who knows like this and
checking if it's a local minimum is that
be hard you can import knapsack here so
is this very weird thing so so I I don't
know I think Burma we got to be very
weary every time we bring cutting on
convexity and we have to bring some
other tool to the table
because with it this is something that
nobody nobody really I think I didn't
take I took for granted for a long time
oftentimes you say well you can get to a
local minimum but you can't even get to
a local minimum you have a smooth non
convex problem you can't even guarantee
that you're at a local minimum unless
you have extra structure to bring to the
table okay so that's my little uh-oh I'm
not no I'm caught preaching to the choir
here
so since hope for the one place where I
see people would appreciate that one
okay so let's move on to the the next
subject remember we had our three
pillars I should have actually brought
in our my my pillar diagram again we had
the notion of the gradient method that's
just on everything first pillar was
acceleration and multi-step next one is
the stochastic gradient algorithm and
just bringing noise into the into the
equation so I said we might want to look
at a function which is the expectation
we're going to kind of looking at
something which is naturally an
expectation and here is an algorithm for
solving that function assuming we can
sample from the distribution and it goes
like this we basically sample every
iteration sample from the distribution
and take a step along the gradient at
that sample okay it's like the gradient
method except now this gradient is a
random variable very simple the state it
has been invented
four thousand times a different I forgot
to add there's one extra here and I
don't know where my friend who was
talking about the cash marshmellow blood
I don't know who's that that's also here
the cash mark method is also stochastic
gradient so we have like five different
inventions of the exact same algorithm
starting with Robinson Munroe and you
have many different analyses we'll do
one today because it's fairly
straightforward ok so this is the now
let me just the reason why it's nice and
the reason why it's kind of interesting
for these kinds of problems is that the
algorithms themselves are trivial the
stochastic gradient algorithm is I
couldn't be easier so even easier than
the gradient method so if we look at our
SVM and we just can't bunch everything
together so it has the right form and I
treat this now as a sample average I
would just sample one of these guys are
random I've compute the sign of commute
the assignment if I get the sign right I
don't do anything if I get the sign
wrong I basically take my old model and
just add in proportional of the new
example
there's a specific phone it's the
perceptron algorithm exactly exactly
this is the perceptron algorithm the
same thing no it's not coordinate
descent because we're moving along this
example we're moving in all coordinates
but only on this example Zi Zi is just
like the current training example it's
but it is called the perceptron
algorithm and this this is basic it's
kind of a well known very very well
studied algorithm and actually will
solve this problem yeah think about the
old true true true true true that's a
good point actually should you should if
you yeah you shrink by a very little
amount yeah you're right you're right
that's fair I don't do that when I run
it though okay yeah that's the bay chain
trip reset right there like technically
that's a great point
technically you really should
incorporate this term but hopefully n is
40 billion and so you don't actually
have to do that you're not even right
usually you don't even regularize this
you just you just take this in Edison
that works really well it's kind of
probably placing ads on your phone as we
speak oh matrix completion is another
one this is a this is a very funny
algorithm where non convexity comes in I
don't know I can't talk about this in
detail today but this is this is just a
fascinating thing what you do is you
take your semi that you know this very
complicated problem you refactor your
decision variable and once you plug in
that Reif factorization turns out that
this is an original nuclear norm problem
is equivalent to this non convex non
linear program which say okay it's kind
of weird we take a complex problem and
rewrite it as a very low dimensional non
convex problem however you there's
analysis that kind of deal with this but
what's really interesting is the
stochastic gradient algorithm here with
this sample on entry compute you're
basically how long am I on that entry so
all that requires is looking at one row
and l1 column of R that confused my
sample residual and then my update again
it's really really simple
only nice look at that row in that call
and this was the that was the algorithm
that kind of was
first published result on the Netflix
prize was just a stochastic gradient
algorithm did really well almost
embarrassing that Netflix didn't try it
so that's kind of a another cute thing
where this thing works coming reasonably
well all right so this kind of is one of
these things where I think this is one
of these ideal algorithm for big data
analysis I mean you have this thing
where the footprints is really reliable
since you work on an example by example
basis it's very robust against noise
which I don't have time to talk about
today we'll see that it converges very
quickly it gives you one algorithm to
prototype everything on and the real
question is just why should this work
that's our question for the day why
should it work all right so here here's
why I should work we're going to start
with the Robinson Munroe example which
is looking at that least squares problem
somebody can tell me the answer it's two
and a half the household value is two
and a half we're just gonna compute the
mean and here's how you compute it right
so step one is you start at X zero we're
going to pick a step size very
particular step size one over two K I
know this in advance so that's your work
you take one step you get one two steps
to get on okay well you get the mean
it's kind of cool you're just doing
you're just taking averaging them and
that's basically what this is doing and
so in general if we minimize this thing
over n terms you always get the mean so
in 1d
very kind of intuitive but we didn't
even need I don't need there's nothing
random here I went through them in order
I'm so cassock it's not really a it just
said that if I have a function written
out of sums I I can march through eat
the derivatives of the individual some
ants and that gives me a good answer but
the remnants actually gets interesting
as soon as you move away from one
dimension look at this problem so this
is at least squares problem the optimal
value is zero zero it's a very
deceptively squares problem it really is
just the identity since x squared plus
is a fancy version of x1 square plus x2
squared guys learned you don't practice
your trig identities there and this
generalizes to any I mean any number of
sunny as we can get one of these and so
if I just start at that point and I take
a constant step size basically then the
operation is just multiplied by that by
a cosine sign matrix and so this the
illustration is that you get very very
slow convergence if you go through them
in order but if I were actually to pick
them at random you actually converge
after a few steps
this is actually tenable this looks like
it's a worst-case example but that's
good it's fine so really points out the
rim this does help us kind of to cancel
these terms out so let me go through a
convergence proof because it's exactly
what I cut out the thing I want to
hammer every example in this talk is
that the convergence of proofs look
almost the same you assume the same
thing we assume that the true function
the expectation sorry I should have an
EMF here so it's a of f we assume the
expectation is strongly convex so the
function we're trying to minimize this
strongly convex and then that each
sample we're kind of getting an unbiased
estimate of the gradient okay so at
every iteration what we're doing is
we're trying to minimize this function f
and we're just getting unbiased sample
of the gradient that's independent of
the past that's basically what we're
assuming and we're assuming the big
assumption we make is that these these
stochastic gradient have bounded noise
or bounded norm you can also if you want
you can assume that they just have bound
a second moment but this is just easier
for today it's bounded norm okay so
here's okay we do the same thing that we
did in the gradient method you take just
right step one always write out what
your iteration is and then step two is
expand out the square now it's almost
always what we do and in that square we
have a few terms let me define the
expected distance the optimal solution
is a K and then we have this expression
so the expected distance at k FK plus 1
is where we were before minus this term
which is just the stochastic gradient
times the difference - the step size and
then we're just going to again now just
compute that we're just going to apply
the fact that these gradients are all
bounded okay so that's our recursion we
just got to kind of clean this one up
and the way you can clean that up is
first if we iterate expectation you can
actually you just conditioned on the
past and take the expected value just
with the current iterate you see that
what you get is the dot product of XK
minus the optimal solution dot product
with the gradient at F the true grading
not the gradient not the stochastic
gradient
that's kind of it we just iterate out
this guy that's the expectation and the
second fact is that we can use we can
actually lower bound this using strong
convexity the point is that this guy is
lower bounded by the different distance
the optimal solution we can go through
the details but it's just trust me
this guy is lower bounded by the
distance the optimal solution this just
uses the definition of strong convexity
twice lower about one and then lower
down too so if we plug that in our
recursion is now much simpler the
distance the optimal solution is step K
plus one is this kind of a one
contracted term to my last iteration
plus a constant offset and now that's
easy to analyze so I've kind of now an
expectation you come you just have to
come up with a step size that makes that
converged okay and there are lots of
different ones so let's just go through
two examples one is we take really big
steps we take big steps so that this guy
actually is an oscillating oscillates
back and forth so that term is negative
first term is negative and that will
achieve is that you'll get a 1 over K
rate after K iterations were a
proportion of 1 over K times the
distance to the optimal solution so it's
a rate of convergence of 1 over K which
remember the optimal method we should
get 1 over K squared actually should be
linear it should be an exponential
convergence so that's even worse so
we're stuck with slow rates here another
way to actually get the same thing which
is actually much more robust in practice
if you want to code this up use constant
step sizes that are small just use
constant steps out there a small and
then every once in a while make your
step size smaller that's what this
doesn't this algorithm this works in
analysis and is kind of awful and
brittle in practice this one is very
this is a nice robust dumb algorithm
this is actually kind of a was initially
proposed by the electrical engineers so
this is kind of their old adaptive
filtering idea from the 60s and you can
analyze this and still get the 1 over K
rate you have to just come up with a
schedule for reducing the step size okay
so in either case we can get a nice 1
over K rate of convergence and you know
what the 1 over K rate is optimal in
this case it's optimal all you have to
think is like let's say I'm trying to
minimize the least squares difference
between X and
between X and some mean X star I should
just write this down it's really easy
you're just minimizing the expected
value of X minus X R squared and just
like makeup Gaussian noise so assume
that at every step when I ask for the
gradient I just add Gaussian noise to it
the central limit theorem says that's
going to take one of her K steps to
average that noise out and that's
basically it so that's why it's
unavoidable so even an Oracle which with
that information with these gradients
couldn't do better figure of a [ __ ] is
somebody was referring to right yeah
yeah so what is zero so they cheat so
they look at a very very special class
so what they have is that they're
stochastic gradient this term you don't
bound it by M Squared what they actually
have is that they have they have the
case where the gradients at the optimal
solution even the stochastic gradient at
the optimal solution vanished and so
actually the you can found this in terms
of the distance of the optimal solution
if you can bound this in terms of the
distance the optimal solution you get a
linear rate of convergence that's all
you need also using something that is
only to make their bound look nice you
don't need that
you still get a linear rate of
convergence you just get a different
linear rate of convergence they use the
and and it's very weird because if you
so not to go on too much of a tangent
but the problem they're looking at is
some of a I transpose X minus B I
squared right which is kind of solving
the least squares problem it actually
equals B exactly they assume that
there's a solution where this vanishes
everywhere and so all if you're doing
length squared I can multiply this by
free multiply this by diagonal matrix
get a completely identical problem and
then they're all equal norm so it's a
little bit of a fishy
it makes the bound looks nice when you
do like squared sampling but it's not
it's not necessarily even true that
uniform sampling isn't better
but that's right that's notthat version
in paper and if you look so here's that
here's the other thing if you look in
poli acts book from 1987 he does prove
that he does prove that the grading is
going to zero if the noise is going to
zero as you approach the optimal
solution you get linear rate of
convergence so Cobb was again so known
to certain batch of Russians there was
like five of them they sat in the office
and smoked all the time I think this is
you see if anybody's actually curious
about that you talked to Katja Steinberg
who was the undergrad researcher in this
lab these old Russian guys were all
smoking and like she had to go bus well
he's yeah nestor also got healthy when
he came to the states then we're asking
not so much so let's look at that so
okay so sadly that that rate is slow but
if we look at it again in terms of just
it's all about how we amortize and look
at these different bounds right if we
look at the Newton method which I didn't
talk about today the Newton method
actually gives you quadratic convergence
you get a doubly exponential convergence
so if I took T steps at the Newton
method and I was in a reasonable base in
a reasonable function I'm basically
taking log log 1 over epsilon is how my
error would scale I'm number of
iteration scales log log 1 over epsilon
but the time to compute the iteration is
going as the dimension cubed I'm
definitely not capable with the data
either it's d squared n the gradient
method is a much faster algorithm just
kind of why we we're studying that and
that's DN and that gets this linear rate
of convergence and our poor stochastic
gradient method is o of D but as we saw
we had examples where it was like the
matrix completion example is constant
amount of work per iteration and then we
have CS over over T so it's a 1 over T
iteration so if I was just looking at
that table I would say it's a little bit
hard to kind of look at exactly what is
the right thing to do however let's say
all I will come to let you do this is a
database my son is stored in a database
and you have to look at each individual
item how many calls to the database you
need so if we look at say let's say we
can do n items and we sample at random
then Newton's method gets to see both
Newton's method and the gradient method
gets some constant towards the optimal
solution
I mean you know okay fine one step
however after one pass over the data
we've made a substantial amount of
progress and if n is a very large number
we probably just stopped after just one
pass through the data and that's why
it's so appealing all on these kind of
applications any questions about
stochastic gradient there's one last
piece goes faster you can tell me I can
stop now if you do guys want to go have
a beer we late in the day so I would
just say there are lots of extensions
that John do Qi was here he'd be jumping
up and down and all these other things
most of them are really boring it's kind
of the same stuff besides your
applications I mean you want to have
this idea that we can get this very nice
we get this polynomial time convergence
for for smooth functions for for non
smooth functions apparently it's slower
the thing is that if I'm looking at an
expectation so the same the increments
themselves are non smooth but in
expectation we don't really know it
could be smooth we don't know the
distribution you can take the expected
value of non smooth functions and get
something smooth and in fact that's what
it seems like this is incredible 1 over
root K is so slow and almost across the
board an optimization if you can prove
something conversions it's almost never
worse than when a root K using these
Khan techniques and and that is that's a
terrible rate it's really slew enough
anyway now cut non-convex the session
was what was done in neural networks and
neural networks this hour it's called
back propagation you can prove that this
converges asymptotically nobody really
knows how fast in that case you can do
stochastic coordinate descent where you
pick a bunch of random coordinates try
to do some steps there and actually
what's a lot of people it's been a very
active area and hopefully will be a lot
talks about this in October it's very a
very interesting area of how to
optimally paralyze this algorithm
okay but that's all I would like to say
about stochastic gradient and we're just
going to end projected gradient and then
we have all the pieces together we have
randomness we brought in we have we have
basically acceleration in momentum which
is a useful concept and now we get
constraints you guys wanted some
constraints and this is not the only way
to deal with constraints oftentimes this
is where interior point methods would
probably be a better idea but there's
just give you something stupid that
works when that is called
X and F is at least smooth this works
for non smooth too but let's make it
simple let's suppose I can solve the
Euclidean projection onto Omega so Omega
is a convex motion let's assume that
that crews some complexity by having
have an algorithm that will just do that
for me this is always unique because
this is a if I square it I get a
strongly convex function and I subject
to convice constraints and this is the
projected gradient method so you take a
step along the gradient so V here will
be negative gradient and then just
project on to the set and iterate so I
have done nothing and actually the nice
thing is the analysis is exactly the
same because of one crucial feature okay
so everybody understand the algorithm is
pretty simple
take a greatest step project onto Omega
the gradient step take an Euclidean
projection of the gradient step on to
the set Omega the closest point in omega
that's my area
okay else clear in that alright so
here's here's the proof of how this
works
and we can go I mean I have 20 minutes
maybe I'll even get in more generality
but let's just do this you just the only
lemma you need is that if I take the
projection onto a convex set that that
doesn't move the points farther apart
they can only get closer when I take the
projection and if I do that now we just
follow our nose what am I going to do
I'm going to look at the distance of the
optimal solution I write out what the
definition of the iteration is I'm kind
of assuming that the true optimal
solution lies in omega somewhere that's
not expansive so I can just pull off the
projection and now you guys now we all
know what to do then that's the non
expansive map and then we get a linear
rate of convergence we basically inherit
all the nice stuff from the gradient
method just using this one lemma and so
constraints they're kind of like in the
picture too so if you have easy
constraints to project onto you get you
can now deal with constraints okay and
and we get this basically the more
general version is that it's called the
proximal point method and this is a good
thing to know about solving today it was
this ridiculous a ridiculous trend at
nips for like three or four years where
you would just write you come up with a
new way of solving this problem
just basically the quadratic simple
quadratic plus P where P would be
something and you do that newspaper done
it's like always the same analysis or
even worse you know he's not here again
anyway I was gonna make fun of Johnny
well you could also do was you would
just like take this and you add great
you do now do stochastic gradient
descent with this projection okay great
this paper is like in the hole all these
algorithms and all these proofs are very
much the same thing and I think it's
fine at first start we were Nesterov and
nemirovsky weren't there to scold us now
they can come and scold us and say you
guys don't have to do that there are
more they're better things for you to
use your time on all these things are
going to work so we want to minimize
this function we basically take a linear
approximation just like we've been doing
we have convar now i have the step size
here and we have P of X I define my
proximal point mapping to just be this
minimization so okay a canonical example
of P let's just have a PB 0 on a set
Omega and infinity off the set Omega
then this is equivalent to the problem
on the previous slide that's a nice
complex function another example where
this would be in norm and so we'll go
through a couple examples in a second
but let me say this is the proximal
gradient method we basically do this
linearization add this little quadratic
term and minimize note that if P isn't
there this is just the gradient method
it's actually kind of interesting what
the gradient descent method is doing is
make a very dumb quadratic approximation
to F and minimize that make another dumb
approximation to F and then minimize
that here we make a del approximation
but we don't do anything with P and we
minimize that that's called the proximal
point method and oops and again we can
analyze this that's what we'll finishes
we'll just do a quick analysis of this
but let me give you again some examples
so I said if P of X this thing is this
is the convex optimization version of
the indicator function
I guess it's log of the of the
combinatorial optimization version of
the indicator function so you just take
your choice there it's 0 on the set and
then infinity off of the set the minus
log of the standard
but this is kind of nice so what it says
is basically I'm infeasible outside the
set so I have an infinite cost and if
we're going to and then I pay no cost if
I'm inside the set okay and the
projection the proximal point mapping is
just the Euclidean projection in that
case more interestingly and kind of like
this is probably the most popular
version is if it's the l1 norm or mu
times the l1 norm the proximal point
mapping does this shrinkage it's like
iterative shrinkage or this is Kabul is
the statistical shrinkage now tying
optimization back to James Stein right
so basically we we just take our new
value it's here if you're inside that
new window you set your your coordinate
to zero and otherwise you shrink towards
the origin so that's the proximal
mapping again that's a non expansive
mapping again the key lemma to make the
proximal point method work and this is
very really not a hard thing to prove I
think I might I can't remember if I left
it in or not but if you want to see the
proof okay I know it's late you want to
see Sebastian come talk to me afterwards
I'll show you the two line proof I think
you're probably the only one with the
stamina left okay if you want to see the
proof is very simple and it's really
kind of intuitive but this is also not
expensive and just just like before this
implies all the racing conversions from
from from the layer method now apply to
this case yeah convex Pacific comebacks
yeah this is actually kind of quite
remarkable it's just convex yeah and
there's an interesting case where Pete
where f is zero is actually a very
interesting algorithm that's called the
proximal point method so where f is zero
is basically all you do is you iterate
dis applying successively the procs
thing and that actually is that that was
a algorithm of Rockefeller this came
this was an algorithm the Fukushima
meaning that combined these two together
this is from the 80s come old class gal
room but at the proximal point method
itself actually a who so who's heard of
a DMM a couple people I was going to
give references at the end because I
don't have time to talk about it a DMM
is applying proximal point method to to
a dual decomposition problem but can't
talk about that
okay yeah I think the projected gradient
method is what Nikhil and some people
use for network clothes recently that a
lot of people yeah oh well recently I
guess
Jonah Sherman Silber I mean for people
that don't make its using those visiting
various other great it seems but
recently it so there's a linear time
algorithm for my explode basically
predicted using using for generator
linear and indeed it's a linear number
of edges that Sherman
I believe that cuz cuz cuz max way min
floor maxwell max-flow min-cut make cut
an english min cut as we wrote is
actually just an l1 problem it says min
l1 subject to box constraints so it's
actually it's a common natural not only
your programming problem so it's nice
that you can actually bring this
analysis to bear so there are other
variants which again I can't talk about
today one of them is a DMM 80 mm is this
proximal point mapping that you use lots
of procs operators allows this is what I
was saying it's one of these modular
algorithms so if you ask them we have a
non negativity constraint and then you
have some other pot you know some other
some constraint you can put those
together and the reason why I didn't
talk about it is because Stephen Boyd
has a beautiful one-hour YouTube you can
watch and he really does a lot better
than me and he has he's very breezy very
readable lecture notes on a tame em that
are I just recommend everybody read
they're really great they're something
to aspire to and scientific writing I
don't know how he does that and then the
other one that's kind of interesting
this is more from the this also is from
1983 in the Soviet Union has the mirror
descent algorithm the mirror descent
algorithm is just using the fact that
gradient descent basically always had a
quadratic term here you can use other
terms you basically just need something
as strongly convex over the constraint
set that you're optimizing so for
example if you're optimizing over the
simplex you can use entropy and that
turns out to be a much faster algorithm
and that's the basis behind mirror
descent but but note that they're
basically it's just the exact same idea
you come to an approximation minimize
that approximation
my legal nurse I don't know there's it
it's in this but I said yeah right no
space and you apply very mean adultery
but he said tonight is not okay it's
nothing too exact the other thing that
Scott weird about mirror descent is
they're really only three algorithms
there's gradient descent there's this
thing where you have used the entropy
over the simplex and then you could have
the quantum entropy over the spectra
he'd run so there are three algorithms
they're called mirror descent they all
kind of have the same analysis but it's
very basically the letter to or real
special cases but yes it's really
beautiful theory but nobody uses any
other other than entropy and quantum
entropy yeah and most people don't even
use quantum entropy is usually not is
usually not faster than what you would
stand because you have to do an SVD
there's usually not faster and welcome
people typically do oh there are other
mirrors oh oh
they bought Sebastian's special photo
you have ten minutes you can come tell
us all right so so that was an hour and
20 that was basically something that was
a the contents of a course that I taught
at Wisconsin last fall Oh
obviously that was too much but it kind
of gives you I think the thing you want
to take away is they're they're really
in kind of fast high dimensional
optimization
there are basically three key ideas
they've been pervasive over the past ten
years and that people have really been
optimizing that the heck out of and
that's that's using kind of accelerated
methods and momentum to kind of speed up
convergence being able to use 2 kasa
gradient both as a way to deal with
noise but also as a way to kind of deal
with the way the data is laid out on
disk and the projected proximal method
is a simple way to integrate constraints
god gives us everything for today
just a reminder tomorrow i'm going to be
a completely different style of talk so
this was kind of implementation and
algorithms kind of given this this
statement tomorrow I want to talk about
how we use optimization to prove thing
and just talk about how we how do Ally
plays a key role in areas of compressed
sensing matrix completion related areas
so that's that will be tomorrow bright
and early we can all go have a nap now
Hey holding up I'm ready to go oh stop
it happy to stick around I'm here all we
get you tomorrow morning I'm here all
week